WILL STAY AND WORK THROUGH THE
WEEKEND.
THANK YOU.
JOINING ME NOW EDITOR IN CHIEF
OF FORBES MEDIA AND FORMER
REPUBLICAN PRESIDENTIAL
CANDIDATE.
NANCY PELOSI SAID THE DEMs ARE
WILLING TO TAKE THEIR OFFER DOWN
FROM 3 TRILLION DOLLARS TO 2
TRILLION DOLLARS.
THE WHITE HOUSE WOULD NOT COME
TO THAT AT LEAST NOT YET.
WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF THIS?
>> I DON’T THINK IT’S THE
NUMBERS, PER SE.
WHETHER IT’S 1, 2 OR 3 TRILLION
DOLLARS.
THAT MATTERS IS WHAT IN THE
PACKAGE.
THE BIGGEST THING THE PRESIDENT
COULD DO TO STIMULATE THE
ECONOMY IN THE THIRD AND 4th
QUARTERS IS SUSPENDINGING THE
PAYROLL TAX.
THAT COULD BE $3,000 EXTRA
DOLLARS PAY TAX FREE.
IF HE SUSPENDS THE PAYROLL TAX
FOR 8 TO 12 MONTHS, THAT WOULD
BE A VERY, VERY POWERFUL
STIMULATANT.
IT’S WHAT THEY DO ON
UNEMPLOYMENT BENEFITS.
RIGHT NOW WHAT THEY SHOULD BE
PUSHING FOR THE REPUBLICANS
INSTEAD OF NEGOTIATING ON THAT,
GO FOR A BIG INDIVIDUAL CHECK
FOR INDIVIDUALS.
WE DID $1200 IN THE SPRING WILL
GO FOR $1500 OR $2,000 GOING IN
THE FALL.
AND CREATE JOBS.
BIG INDIVIDUAL CHECKS AND
SUSPENDING THE PAYROLL TAX.
THAT WOULD REALLY BOOST THE
ECONOMY.
>> Harris: YOU KNOW WHAT IS
FASCINATING ABOUT WHAT YOU ARE
SAYING, LOOK, THERE ARE SMALLER
GOVERNMENT PEOPLE OUT THERE.
YOU HAVE TO MEET THIS MOMENT
WITH SOMETHING BIG.
THAT’S WHAT I HEAR FROM YOU.
I WANT TO GET YOUR TAKE ON THE
UNEMPLOYMENT RATE WHICH FELL
BELOW EXPECTATIONS LAST MONTH.
DOWN A THIRD STRAIGHT MONTH FROM
A HIGH OF 14.7% IN APRIL.
AS FOR THE JOBS ADDED, 1.8
MILLION IN JULY.
DOWN FROM NEARLY 4.8 MILLION
ADDED THE MONTH BEFORE BUT NOT
AS CLOSE TO THE 21 MILLION LOST
IN APRIL.
WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF ALL OF THIS?
>> WELL, HEALING AN ECONOMY THAT
TOOK A SAVAGE HIT IN MARCH AND
APRIL THIS IS GOOD PROGRESS
ESPECIALLY WITH THE BURST IN
CORONAVIRUS CASES IN THE
SOUTHWEST.
YOU CONTINUE THAT IN SEPTEMBER
AND OCTOBER, YOU WILL GET THE
UNEMPLOYMENT RATE DOWN TO SINGLE
DIGITS.
IF ANYONE IN THE SPRING THOUGHT
WE WOULD GO FROM 25% DOWN TO 8%
IN UNEMPLOYMENT, PEOPLE WOULD
SAY THAT’S PHENOMENAL.
IT CAN’T HAPPEN, BUT IT IS
HAPPENING.
WE DO THE RIGHT THING ON THE
PAYROLL TAX AND INDIVIDUAL
CHECKS, YOU COULD SEE THAT RATE
DO EVEN BETTER.
BUSINESSES ARE UNCERTAIN.
I DON’T THINK YOU WILL GET THE
REAL REACH OF THE ECONOMY UNTIL
PEOPLE KNOW WHAT WILL HAPPEN IN
JANUARY.
THAT’S FUNDAMENTAL.
WE HAVE THE CHOICE THIS
NOVEMBER.
>> Harris: AND A VACCINE
OBVIOUSLY.
I WANT TO GET TO THIS.
PRO-TRUMP SUPER PAC SAID IT
WON’T SILENCED BY THE WOKE ELITE
AFTER FACEBOOK BANNED ITS
ADVERTISING.
THE HEAD OF THE GROUP SAID THEY
WON’T BE SILENCED BY SILICONE
VALLEY ELITE AS WE EXPOSE THE
REAL JOE BIDEN.
WE HAVE REALLOCATED OUR ENTIRE
FACEBOOK BUDGET TO OTHER ONLINE
PROGRAMS SO AMERICANS CAN SEE
THE TRUTH."
FACEBOOK IS NOW IN THE FACT
CHECKING BUSINESS.
DO THEY HAVE A RESPONSIBILITY TO
DO THAT?
OR IS THIS STOMPING ON FREE
SPEECH?
>> FACEBOOK AND THE OTHER
HIGH-TECH GIANTS, I THOUGHT THEY
DID THE RIGHT THING TELL NOW,
UNLESS IT WAS OFFENSIVE THEY
WOULD NOT POLICE EVERY PIECE ON
LINE.
THAT WAS THE RIGHT THING TO DO.
DOING WHAT THEY JUST DOES STOKES
THE ANTI-HIGH-TECH ATTITUDE ON
THE LEFT AND THE RIGHT.
CONSERVATIVES AND LIBERTARIANS
WOULD BE THE ALLIES OF FACEBOOK.
THEY KICKED THEM IN THE SHINS.
THAT WAS A MISTAKE ON FACEBOOK’S
PART.
THEY SHOULD SAY WE WILL LET THE
PUBLIC JUDGE WHETHER YOU LIKE
A PARTICULAR POLITICAL AD.
>> Harris: THEY CHERRY PICKED
THIS PRO-TRUMP SUPER PAC FROM
ADVERTISING.
>> AND THEY ARE ASKING FOR
TROUBLE.
THEY WILL DIG THEMSELVES IN